there was a couple in san francisco
black couple yeah they got their home
appraised for uh 900 000 yep
they removed themselves yeah
from
so they got the house appraised they got
uh offered for 900 000 dollars which
they thought was low relative to the
county they're in marin county in san
francisco marin marin who gives a [ __ ]
so then they had their white friend they
went to a different appraisal company
and told their white friend put it in
your name yeah they removed themselves
and they leave the property yeah took
the pictures of themselves and their
family away from the property took them
all down so they basically whitewashed
the whole property the appraisal went
from 900 000 to 1.4 million which is in
line with the county of average but 500
in what's supposed to be a real
progressive city it's supposed to be a
real haven for progress marin is
yeah marin is outside
yeah of san francisco how far outside uh
far enough where it's like uh you you'd
want to not deal with any of that
progressive [ __ ] oh really yeah like
imagine like long island okay yeah so
imagine you know long island is not
necessarily like the the last bastion of
progressivism in the east right right
right but williamsburg might be okay so
that's how i would look at it but still
it's it's really interesting man like
there's also another thing everybody's
making this about race maybe they were
just [ __ ] ugly like maybe these
people are so disgusting
and that we know exists yeah yeah and
that's [ __ ] up and also who is this
new guy that moved in the house is this
new guy famous
no it's just the appraisal right but the
new guy's pictures are in the house
so oh i don't know if they put up new
pictures from what i read they didn't
they just they didn't put up pictures of
them still black family pictures in the
house no there's just no pictures
they just took all the pictures down
yeah so maybe they have horrible
pictures
maybe these people don't know how to put
pictures up and then they maybe you
should see what they look like if we can
find out what they look like 500 000
or they yeah put the pictures in bad
places in the appraiser was it the scent
no that can't be that you know what they
say when an ugly person moves into your
neighborhood everybody just leaves
hundreds of white people just leave 100
percent yeah
i've heard this for a while like this
has happened over and over and like we
did a study in like college where like
they did the same thing and really yeah
like they'd point us out and i think
it's worth offering this as a service
so
as white people we can go fake own your
homes yeah if you're a black person or a
person of color in america and you want
to get a higher appraisal i will come in
and i will be there to show the person
you're home and i'll just collect a
small fee we're trying to make them yeah
go up yeah come on yeah yeah it looks
like a practice shower
yeah that's trendy that's cool or
make sure if you are buying a home you
buy from a black family
with me oh you got a discount yeah yeah
you get a great shot off you get a great
crazy flip that's the real black friday
right there
get yourself a [ __ ] deal yeah that's
a good point yo that is kind of crazy or
if you're a black person go whiteface
100 you've got to go live yeah 100 but
you know what's crazy about this like
this is really [ __ ] up this is where
you know they talk about like
institutional racism and how like racism
is baked in because
think about specifically the loan that
you get to purchase a home is based on
the appraised value of that home
yeah right so it's like
by a black person just being in the home
it's reducing the value of it and then
making well i guess it's making it more
affordable for another person to buy
yeah but you're that person would have
to be black for it to even out for it to
even out exactly but then it
effectively reduces a black family's
ability to to gain wealth in the same
way yes so they're missing out on 500
000 simply because they're black it's
like a modern-day red lining like they
can't keep you out of the neighborhood
but they can you can make less just be
in there this is that critical race
theory ship bro
this is this is it ties into something
like this right it's like how like race
is intersectional
and the way that it affects all these
things in life is not specifically like
i'm going to be rude to that guy because
he's black right it's there might be
appraiser of in there that doesn't think
he's racist
and he's in there appraising the house
with racist undertones without even
[ __ ] realizing it [ __ ] white face
liberal i love it
i love it but he walks in that just
smells like jerk chicken everywhere he's
like
not worth 500k bro honestly i would pay
more for a house that smells like i
think this is a cap i need to see the
[ __ ] what's up
this is fake story this is amazing
food slaps bruh can you imagine a house
smell like [ __ ] hamburger helper
get out of here i think a house on my
black feels probably cleaner honestly
100 percent
like they shower before they go to bed
that's just crazy and they wash their
ass showers
i cup some of the soap suds from my
pubes
and then i just splash it against my
taint and i pick the toilet paper out of
my butt okay so that's cool yeah if
you're listening to this and trying to
praise andrew's apartment yeah how much
would it be worth now a little appraisal
cuck
no but in all seriousness there's no
[ __ ] way i can't believe that this is
real i can believe like maybe a hundred
thousand but not five hundred dollars
well i'm curious the thing time is off
i'm pretty confident like this has
happened before and i've seen other
stuff yeah there's been other laws i'm
curious like one-third of the value of
the home if you have two different
appraisers how different is that was the
wonderful comments different appraisal
companies so that might affect it some
also
how uh soon was this done last one to
the new one
i don't think there was much very true
because it could have been a long time
they could have the market went crazy
the value could have maybe it was a
black appraiser the second time or the
first or the first time also ain't
nobody buying this black [ __ ] he
probably was walking around like
[Laughter]
the appraiser
in all seriousness i think what could
have happened is if there was a long
time i don't know how much time was done
you know the rental market went crazy
like pre-pandemic to during the pandemic
like people want to move out of the city
they want to go to like live in homes
with some land or whatever and uh prices
for homes went [ __ ] nuts i mean when
we were down in miami it was unreal so
maybe the market what's up there's one
month between one that's crazy
something's off here yo that that
something's off here yeah crazy money
yeah crazy month went up 500 000 yeah
well what would they give an amount was
it a crypto or something like that were
they given the amount of crypto maybe it
was a crypto appraisal
and crypto tumbled lately so
um
now they've got to find this guy who did
the appraisal and fire yeah that's
[ __ ] up but which guy's wrong there's
the interesting thing is the 1.4 [ __ ]
up or is the 900 [ __ ] up you got it
yeah but if you're stealing you're gonna
sue the 900 000 company hell yeah yeah
you're going to say there's obviously
some credence effect that is worth a
half a million dollars or more a half a
million dollars is [ __ ] crazy all
right but it could be racist the other
way
i'm gonna overrate this house it's a 900
000 house yeah but because they're black
i'm gonna overrate it oh no because it
was white people i'm gonna overrate it
yeah which is still racist yeah but not
as [ __ ] up because the first one was
true in value
and the second one was just like oh i'm
going to give you extra points because
you're white yeah and i'm pretty sure
that institution is [ __ ] up in general
just appraisers because it's like a lot
of power through a whole lot of money if
i come through an inspection that's a
fire just like no one talks about that
you've got to be correct yeah
something's off right
because it's almost like the restaurant
dudes that come and see like every other
code and [ __ ] like
but like to put that much power there
has to be like systems or something like
that in order to grade right like it's
gonna be like checklists and all that
there must be yeah like checking the
foundation all the stuff like the walls
i guess competition is the checks and
balances
is one of the biggest things uh you get
multiple appraisals and i always say
neighborhood comps yeah that's the other
thing
so the 1.4 million they were saying was
in line for marin county that's how you
say it right yeah yeah and then 900 000
was clearly below property value that's
why they were like let's get this it's
usually like a per square foot price and
then there's a range and then you get a
little bit more specific on the quality
what's on the market blah blah
sums up
yeah they need to figure that out i mean
that should be a lawsuit yeah i mean it
is i think they're showing they are
suing yeah good we got to find out who
this person is how often do like do you
get your place of praise by more than
one institution often
i don't know i've never sold the house
no right i don't know so
it would be common practice to just get
it appraised once and then you would
just go with that and then lose out on
500 000 i assume you're going to get it
done a couple times i mean that person
should be put in jail you potentially
could have stole 500 000 yeah
yeah that's theft
whoa yeah i don't know if it gets done
multiple times though because you are
paying for that
uh
part of like yeah that's their hustle
[ __ ]
[Applause]